quando recebeu o convite pra falar de um
tema tão intrigante então conspirador
tão subversivo quanto em busca dos
porquês o câncer bom mas que por que
afinal a minha formação em filosofia faz
com que a idéia de por dois porque se
abra um 'extraordinário' né
quem se aventura a entender um pouco da
língua portuguesa se depara com essa
grande dificuldade de entender o uso dos
porquês tem porque junto com assentos em
por que separado porque no início de uma
frase de um jeito porque no final é de
outro é é um monte de coisas para gravar
e saber o sentido de cada porque a idéia
de cada um deles
este por específico do nosso encontro
junto com acento é que é o porquê essa
fato subversivo
mas porquê porque é um substantivo ele
pergunta pela essência das coisas
ele pergunta profundamente pela
identidade de tudo e de tudo que está aí
e daí o comércio com esse tudo falando
um pouquinho lá do final do século 19
né quando a ciência sobretudo com a
segunda revolução industrial a ciência
se desenvolvem tremendamente grandes
tecnologias surgem o uso a manipulação
do petróleo com a química orgânica
principalmente e outras novas fontes de
energia novos produtos é de repente a
humanidade se descobriu deus nós eu
posso transformar tanta coisa posso
fazer tudo e aos poucos ciências foram
se especializando as pessoas foram se
especializando os conhecimentos foram se
aprofundando em cada área
e à medida que se aprofundava se
distanciavam e foram aos poucos
fragmentando próprio ser humano o que
gerou uma disputa enorme em ti entre
estes novos conhecimentos porque cada um
queria conhecer e saber e explicar
melhor tudo
à medida que cada um na verdade se
isolava
de tudo isso foi bom em vários aspectos
que graças à especialização se conseguiu
entender o mundo de uma forma
extraordinária ea gente não olha isso só
como elemento negativo pelo contrário
foi extremamente positivo
só que não resolveu o problema da
humanidade não resolver ou pelo menos o
problema de toda a humanidade que a
ideia é essencial que é aquela ambição
mais legítima de cada um de nós quer
simplesmente sermos felizes nos trouxe
coisas nos trouxe objetos nos trouxe uma
infinidade de bens conseguiu contribuir
muito para diminuir a fome no mundo
aumentando produção de alimentos
a medicina teve um avanço fantástico mas
ainda essas áreas todas não conseguiram
se entender não conseguiram se unir não
conseguiram se dar as mãos para resolver
o grande problema da felicidade e daí um
grande pensador deste período final do
século 19 fazendo uma crítica todo esse
processo chamado de burro seu relógio da
tecnologia ele diz que as ciências média
as coisas sem conhecer o que estão
pedindo ou seja sem conhecer a profunda
essência das próprias coisas e eu como
educador aqui eu entendo as próprias
coisas no processo educativo
sobretudo num processo que vai de quando
a criança chega pra conviver sair do
seio familiar da primeira instituição a
liz pai mãe e irmãos
aquele ambiente seguro quando ela sai
dali ea lançada na escola até o momento
que ela sai de lá o que importa aqui
importa a travessia não importa muito
da onde a criança estava indo até porque
as realidades de onde ela vem são das
mais variadas para onde ela vai
também é um universo gigantesco muito
bem recentemente colocado aqui um milhão
de possibilidades
mas de repente há um momento em que toda
essa diversidade esse encontro em que
toda essa diversidade vai conviver e
esse lugar a escola ea escola não é o
ponto de partida e nem o ponto de
chegada
a escola é a travessia e aqui
para exemplificar eu uso muito o caminho
de santiago de compostela
as pessoas não falam de onde partiram
pra caminhar pra fazer o caminho de
santiago
as pessoas também não falam onde elas
pararam elas farão falam o que viveram
enquanto caminharam elas falam da
travessia ea escola é a travessia
como disse guimarães rosa através de um
parto de um dos seus personagens joão
que a coisa não está nem na partida nem
na chegada mas justamente nesse período
de caminhada a partida como já disse o
seio familiar
à chegada o tão almejado diploma ea
escola e esta travessia pois todos
aqueles valores que vão dizer o que vai
fazer com a tua profissão há serviço de
quito vai colocar a sua profissão para
encher o bolso te dá status prestígio
outro vai colocar a sua profissão como
muito bem antes foi colocado aqui por
vários dos meus amigos que palestraram
ou a serviço de uma causa maior
o que se impõe hoje pato realmente ser
feliz
tudo isso se constrói em uma fase
extraordinária da nossa existência que a
nossa vida escolar que é justamente onde
está o problema
concordo inter a escola é o problema ea
escola precisa assumir se como sendo o
problema
o primeiro passo é assumir para depois
tentar de uma forma honesta resolver
isso
é impressionante como as famílias
escolhem a escola levando em conta
preparada melhor o vestibular e para mim
o vestibular esta imagem aí né mesmo tu
afogando
até o último instante instalar
contemplando quem está conseguindo o
espetáculo de quem está passando porque
assim ó vestibular aqui no titanic né
o titanic que tinha lá várias classes
sociais várias pessoas gentis todos os
tipos
antes todas as crenças né e assim como
vestibular o titanic não tinha botes
salva vidas para todo mundo
não é todo mundo que vai conseguir como
no titanic não foi todo mundo que
conseguiu
eu não vou nem precisar dizer quem foi
que conseguiu no titanic vestibular é
igual porque a diferença de quem vem de
uma estrutura de escola particular e ao
trabalho em ambas com quem vem de uma
escola pública é gigantesca gigantesca
diferença
por mais que de uma forma muito honesta
todo mundo envolvido nesses processos
tentem dar o seu melhor e dão seu melhor
mas é que o problema está muito muito
atrás e o processo de transformação é
extremamente lento e às pressas pessoas
realmente precisam ser mais honestas
profundamente honesto é pra poder
realmente transformar esta diferença
esta diferença tão grande entre uma
realidade outro mas vale uma self né
tendo ao fundo o mesmo que tu morra nos
seguintes nuno instantes seguintes
e aqui há de se melhorar o que também
falaram aqui de uma forma incrível que
eu me identifiquei muito
é né fase então de travessia no que isso
vai dar enfoque esses dias falando numa
turma de alunos meus eles criticando a
corrupção neste país afinal quem né não
está acompanhando e uma série de coisas
que que mostram a corrupção desvio do
nosso dinheiro e tal
a agente pergunta bons são adultos todo
mundo adulto nela os bandidos são
adultos estupradores são adultos mas
eles nasceram de uma bobina de um
repolho adultos
eles nunca foram crianças
nunca foram adolescentes jovens nunca
foram e o que aconteceu que ninguém
nessa fase da vida que conviveu com eles
esteve com eles conseguiu dar a eles um
novo destino novo ponto de chegada
podem ter passado por nós passaram
talvez com certeza cada vez mais pelos
professores e o que eles fizeram então
há de se assumir um papel fundamental
professores e também à família nesta
fase extraordinária da vida que a
travessia de olhar no olho das crianças
sentado do lado deles abraçá lo sim
dizer o quanto eles são importantes
ouvir o espaço onde eles vivem conhecer
a realidade conhecer a família saber
quem são chamados pelo nome perceber num
dia que eu cheguei os encontra na aula
que aqueles não tão legal que alguma
coisa ontem à noite pode ter acontecido
em casa né
como é que eu vou lidar com isso mas eu
tenho lá um livro uma apostila um
conteúdo programático para vencer
eu só tenho 45 e 50 minutos de aula como
fica
dane se a pessoa é mais importante o que
ela vai levar de valores nessa travessia
o mais importante é extremamente mais
importante nesta fase da vida a
segurança que tudo a ela como adulto e
educador que está junto dela no afeto no
olhar amigo pra ela ter certeza que a
pessoa que é o bem dela está com ela do
que aquele conteúdo que te cobram que
tudo dê a eles e é nessa fase que a
criança forma a autoestima
essa autoestima ela vai ser fruto da
estima que nós tivermos por ela do
carinho e da confiança que nós passarmos
para ela e daí ela vai se olhar mais um
leão e até pra nos decepcionar ela vai
dar o melhor dela e vai desenvolver tudo
que ela puder desenvolver porque se ela
errar
e ela vai errar todo mundo erra
ela vai errar mas ela vai nos ter do
lado dela dizer tenta de novo faz de
novo
corre atrás de novo vai conseguir vai
chegar onde não interessa à chegada à
escola a travessia faz o que tu quiser
fazer faz aquilo no qual for melhor
desenvolve o teu melhor e eu como
profissional eu vou saber avaliar se
tudo eu tenho o melhor não sabe
especificar mente o meu conteúdo
até porque muito bem colocado antes a
quito a da internet hoje tem todos os
conteúdos de uma forma muito melhor com
professores na sala de aula consegue em
50 minutos
tudo tem um vídeo tem um milhão de vídeo
sobre o mesmo conteúdo né não segundo o
professor o termo nesta fase especial da
vida
eu precisei de estima e de segurança que
ninguém pode as duas iniciativas os seus
dons as suas habilidades
é disso que precisa e te kanawa
canalizar isso para o bem for bom para o
coletivo para o outro e isso é descobrir
se contra o vírus aluno se descobrir da
criança você descobrir
não que o aluno se descobrir não olhar
como aluno mas para aquele ser humano
ainda pequeno ainda tão jovem
aquele ser humano que ainda é uma argila
na mão do goleiro que pode vir a ser
tudo para esta criança desse ser humano
se desenvolver plenamente em final a se
descobrir e ensiná lo a se descobrir não
significa que tu vai dizer a ele quem
ele é e quais as habilidades qual a
vocação dele descobrir se é dar todo
suporte todas as condições nas quais ele
precisa para ele desenvolver o que ele é
diferente do que tu kehl do que o sonho
dele e principalmente é mais difícil
principalmente não que os pais querem
dele porque é impressionante quando a
gente atende os pais e eu atendo muitos
a gente ouve dos pais o que eles querem
dos seus filhos ea distância tão grande
em relação ao que os filhos querem deles
mesmos
é impressionante essa distância
muitos pais projeto nos filhos aquilo
que não conseguiram ser e fazer e querem
que o filho faz só com o filho que é
outra coisa
ele quer ser feliz ele quer realizar o
sonho dele não do pai da mãe dele
eu conheci uma menina que ela fez no
segundo ano do ensino médio vestibular
para medicina passou na unix né só que
ela não queria ela queria fazer
sociologia
o pai quase expulso ela de casa ela
tirou o primeiro lugar na ufrgs em
sociologia naquele ano
hoje é doutor em sociologia ela quis
fazer sociologia um certo momento ela
teve que morar com a tia
o pai queria transmitir seu pai era
médico não é um frustrado que nunca
conseguiu passar no vestibular de
medicina queria que a filha realizasse o
sonho dele nessa canalha
coitadinha da agulha então é muito isso
né
então nós só seremos aperfeiçoada dores
das coisas melhoradores de qualquer
coisa
se antes a gente se assumir como se eles
aperfeiçoável agentes assumir como um
constante vir a ser morrer e renascer
constantemente como muito bem foi falado
aqui antes a gente precisa se assumir
assim né porque somos assim
e é isso que nos abre um leque
gigantesco de possibilidades né que
angustiante porque não tem a segurança
de onde vai chegar mas não tem o que
pague essa liberdade né de poder chegar
muitos lugares e aqui tem um ingrediente
que eu tenho convicção que é fundamental
além da questão do afeto da autoestima
da segurança
eu tenho convicção que para a autêntica
verdadeira profunda e sólida da
felicidade
nós precisamos ter uma espiritualidade e
espiritualidade não significa uma
religião mas significa uma profunda
consciência do outro da existência do
outro e do outro como a única
possibilidade para minha mesma
felicidade
precisa ver o outro como o teu não eu e
ao mesmo tempo como complemento desse
teu eu e só esse eu que só será pleno
profundamente pleno realizado se é que
isso seja possível
mas em conexão com esse outro isso pra
minha espiritualidade ea percepção do
outro e tu como um mesmo dentro de um
lugar de um espaço e um tempo isso a
espiritualidade a conexão destas coisas
a conexão de tudo isto e daí a
necessidade da aceitação da presença de
uma ideia ou uma realidade uma realidade
infinita em nós e no outro
essa realidade que nos amarra que nos
ata e aí a gente encontra mais ou menos
a resposta do porquê de nós como diz
rubem alves a vida acontece sempre no
presente não é ela quem está chegando
não é no vestibular não é o que eu quero
ser no futuro é aqui agora que eu vou
fazer essas conexões é aqui agora que eu
vou parar e olhar o outro e atender à
necessidade dele agora tu não abreviar a
vida não empurra pra viver amanhã tu não
realiza vida amanhã ela não espera está
acontecendo tem que realizar sempre num
instante presente ea nossa essência como
a flor de lótus que se desenvolve num
pântano na água podre suja é que nasce
uma das flores mais extraordinárias que
tem que é o símbolo do budismo né a
também nós na nossa existência são as
dificuldades do dia a dia os conflitos
lula que vão nos desenvolver que vão nos
construir então o conflito é a melhor
coisa do mundo
a dificuldade é a melhor coisa do mundo
o problema é a melhor coisa do mundo
meu deus estranho se não tiverem
problemas vocês vão estacionar na vida
são essas coisas que nos lá vão nos
lapidar que nos moldam - lanço do
crescimento para a superação é e ali
nesse pântano que nasce a flor da nossa
essência e que responde ao porquê da
nossa existência ao porquê de estarmos
por exemplo agora aqui um poeta
português chamado teixeira de pascoaes
diz que sentencia das coisas é de
natureza poética se revela muito mais na
inspiração do luar do que na frieza né
da razão e eu concordo plenamente com
isso
acharemos os porquês não de forma
racional mas de uma forma poética em
volta de uma fogueira ou aqui muito
obrigado
o